[Music]
First Descendant is a
next-generation third-person root shooter game using Unreal Engine 5. It is being
developed so that you can enjoy cross-play between consoles and PCs, including Xbox Series X and S Xbox One, and enjoy free play.
In Dunt, players
become Heirs and
fight against invaders for the survival of mankind.
Heirs are player characters, and
have a variety of unique concepts and fighting styles.
Players explore the Ingris continent through Heirs,
experience the story,  You can
play various characters alone or in cooperative play. You
can also experience a raid with a giant boss with up to 4 players cooperative play. You
can experience high-density team play through various standing and buying by giant
boss  We are working on improving the feedback received from players in the beta test last year
and
developing new content. The
screen you are seeing now is the actual gameplay video
of the Xbox Series x, which is being released for the first time.
High-quality graphics using Unreal Engine 5  We are working
hard to make it work stably. A
new successor is also under development. This
successor is designed to
experience a unique concept of play using fire. We are
also
developing a new character with magnetic defense and flight skills.  We are
developing new apps in various environments so that you can explore a lot and experience an immersive story, and we are continuously developing a new type of boss
raid.
And we
are also introducing a cosmetic system that many people have requested.
Different concept skins for each character  will be
provided, and we
will support you to show off your individuality through decoration items. The
Graffley Book, which received the most feedback, has completely changed the system.
In addition, we are continuously improving the
jump motion gun sound
ui and ux by reflecting feedback,
and
a system that can modify the successor skill is also being developed.  We are
preparing to provide an auditory experience.
Finally, we will give you the news you have been waiting for the most.
Currently, we are aiming for a release within the year,
and ahead of that, we will launch a
cross-play beta on PC and consoles, including Xbox Series X and S in August.  The
beta test will be
held for a week from August 22nd to August 28th, and you
can apply through the official website from today, so
we ask for a lot of participation from players
[Music]